and durant the rebound that's with a
little momentum now irving a deep one is
good
that's just a good move both of these
guys know that they're going to get open
shots here's durant here's the double
irving on the attack sets up mills does
he have another he does paddy wills you
got to play smart basketball all right
irving comes up with a steal
irving racing it finds the rant for the
hammer keep an eye on this now now watch
see you see him he cut he caught him he
saw him coming
beautiful but they're only getting one
look at the basket durant elevates and
knocks it down
of 26 points that's been the difference
mills again he got it patty mills on
fire his fourth three of the night oh
that's why he's here 13
foul shots in a close game this isn't
the first game that this has happened
durant
gets the angle and puts it in
that's staying small with durant at the
five here's durant another good angle
more cash for k.d
irving the cross over the dish deranged
short on a three follows it up another
chance irving he got
massive three for kyrie
durant off the double
curry will fire
cupid
seth curry
he averaged 15 in philly this year and
then he came here he's averaging 15
again it's nice to see him now durant
open on the attack gives it back mills
drops it two to shoot mills fires
[Music]
hits
paddy mills
back from down under